bonjour à toutes et à tous très bonne
année et bienvenue dans cette première
vidéo de 2024 je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver aujourd'hui car nous
allons traiter d'un sujet un peu
particulier je ne sais pas si on peut
véritablement qualifier ça de théorie
mais dans tous les cas c'est une
réflexion que j'ai en tête depuis un
très long moment c'est une vidéo qui
devait sortir il y a plusieurs mois et
je me décide enfin en compagnie de mon
variant hosef de vous la proposer
J'espère de tout cœur que cela vous
plaira n'hésitez pas à partager vos
ressentis en commentaire sur ce ne
tardons pas plus longtemps place au
mystère si ce n'est l'un des plus grands
de ces trois nouvelles phases néanmoins
juste avant de commencer laissez-moi
vous présenter notre partenariat du jour
c'est un produit que j'utilise au
quotidien c'est Nord VPN avec Nord VPN
vous pouvez changer votre localisation
en un clic et grâce à cela vous pourrez
contourner les géorestrictions et
accéder aux films et séries disponibles
dans d'autres pays pour les fans de
Marvel par exemple c'est un excellent
moyen de voir ou revoir les dernières
productions c'est un bon moyen aussi de
profiter de meilleurs tarifs sur vos
achats en ligne ou vos voyages et
surtout c'est un outil qui protégera
vous et vos appareils connectés des
sites malveillants ou autres criminels
du web mais cela ne s'arrête pas là car
Nord VPN vous propose une offre inédite
seulement du 29 novembre jusqu'au9 9
janvier si vous habitez en France ou en
Belgique vous pourrez profiter d'une
remise exceptionnelle sur les
abonnements de 2 ans avec en plus 4 mois
offert et encore mieux vous recevrez une
carte cadeau Amazon de 10 20 ou 30 €
selon l'abonnement de 2 ans choisi un
bon moyen pour se faire plaisir ou pour
faire en profiter votre entourage c'est
une offre exclusive et limité du 29
novembre jusqu'au 9 janvier je le
rappelle donc si vous êtes intéressé
n'hésite nésitez pas à accéder au lien
disponible en description je remercie
Nord VPN d'avoir sponsorisé la
vidéo comme vous le savez dans le MCU
Marvel adapte de grands événements des
comics pour leurs films et séries alors
quand on a su qu'Avengers Secret Wars
serait le dernier grand film de ce
nouveau cycle la fameuse saga du
multiver et bien plusieurs grosses
questions se sont posées car Secret Wars
c'est un événement immense dans
l'histoire des comics évidemment il y a
l'interrogation de la présence de
docteur Doom encore plus depuis les
récentes news en to hang Kong et qui est
un personnage plus que majeur de
l'événement Secret Wars il y a aussi la
question de l'adaptation des incursions
de la possible arrivée du beyonderer de
la présence des Black Swan des Black
Priest de l'avèement des Illuminati de
la fin du multivver et cetera et cetera
néanmoins moi je vous avoue que de mon
côté s'il y a bien une interrogation
très précise qui m'est toujours resté en
tête depuis l'annonce d'Avengers Secret
Wars et bien c'est l'adaptation du cas
Owen ris alias
moléculem laissez-moi mieux vous
éclairer dans Secret Wars nous sommes
témoins de l'avènement des incursions
une contraction du multivère qui
déclenche la collision entre deux
univers parallèles et provoquant par
conséquent la destruction de ces
derniers sauf qu'en réalité ces
incursions ne sont pas le fruit du
hasard elles ont une origine et cette
origine
c'est Owen ris alias molcu man simple
technicien Owen est un scientifique qui
comme beaucoup d'autres personnages de
l'univers Marvel a conduit une
expérience qui va lui octroyer des super
pouvoirs en l'occurrence ici ces
pouvoirs concernent la manipulation des
moléculle toutefois contrairement à
d'autres vilains l'accident d'Owen est
quelque peu unique mais pourquoi cela et
bien parce qu'elle est à l'origine
provoquée par les Beyonders des êtres
omnipotents vivant au-delà du multivers
si les Beyonders ont manipulé la vie de
Wen ris c'est pour faire de ce
personnage une singularité dans son
propre univers et ce dans la totalité du
multiver pour être un peu plus précis à
cause des beanders Owen et ses variants
sont pour chacun d'entre eux une sorte
de bombe à retardement dès que l'un
d'entre eux va mourir il emportera avec
lui son univers permettant ainsi en
tuant tous les Owen en même temps
d'anéantir le multivers dans sa
globalité en un seul coup l'objectif
principal que se sont donnés les
beanders en fait nous avons tendance à
l'oublier car l'événement Times runout
qui précède Secret Wars et Secret Wars
en lui-même en soi met en vedette
énormément de personnag que ce soit du
côté des gentils ou des méchants mais le
personnage véritablement clé dans cette
histoire sans qui tout ça n'existerait
pas et bah c'est bien molécul man grâce
à sa condition docteur Doom et le
molécule man de la terre 616 vont
pouvoir contrecarer les beonders en
tuant et se servant de la totalité des
moléculle man des autres univers et ce à
des moments différents du temps pour
empêcher la destruction complète du
multiver en un seul coup mais qui de
l'autre côté va générer des incursions
car la mort d'un owenris engendre
forcément la mort de son univers les
incursions bien qu'horribles ont permis
de donner une chance aux univers de
survivre et c'est comme ça notamment que
Doom a pu limiter la casse à la fin du
multiver via battle World et
accessoirement utiliser le pouvoir des
molécules men tué bref vous l'aurez donc
compris Owen est très important et donc
par conséquent le cas de son adaptation
peut et je dirais même doit faire
surface son cas nous l'avions déjà
évoqué quelqu fois en vidéo sans jamais
avoir véritablement creusé jusqu'à
aujourd'hui car je pense avoir une belle
piste à vous
proposer bon déjà j'aimerais quand même
vous mettre un warning car il faut
souligner l'importance du concept
d'adaptation de comics pour les films du
MCU je ne pense pas du tout qu'Owen sera
amené dans les film et plus que ça
encore l'adaptation de son cas de sa
singularité si je puis dire serait
beaucoup plus subti que l'on le pense
comme toujours les comics peuvent partir
loin très loin par moment et les films
quant à eux se veuillent beaucoup plus
accessi je dirais plus grand public
entre guillemets mais vous allez plus
comprendre avec la suite de la vidéo
nous devons revenir sur Multiverse of
madness car ce film apporte énormément
de détails de conceptes et autres
explications concernant le futur et il
est clair qu'énormément d'éléments
seront réutilisés pour le grand final de
la saga du multiver déjà tout simplement
le concept d'incursion jusqu'à la sortie
d'antman quantouan ou même the marvels
Doct strange 2 qui est un film de la
phase 4 était le seul à nous amener les
incursions et pire que ça encore il est
le seul à véritablement pour le moment
exploiter ce concept et à l'insérer au
cœur de son histoire néanmoins si le
concept d'incursion est au cœur de
l'intrigue de Multiverse of manness qui
est le héros principal du film qui est
celui qui est relié à tous les nouveaux
concepts amenés dans le long métrage et
ce peu importe l'univers c'est Doctor
Strange je vous l'ai toujours dit mais
docteor strange est un héros très
particulier dans le MCU et devra l'être
encore plus dans cette nouvelle saga
outre ces thématiques fortes comme le
multivers ou
l'extradimensionnel et bien à contrario
des autres héros via son second film
docte strange a déjà appréhendé les plus
grandes problématiques auxquelles
devront faire face les Avengers dans
quelques années tout comme Tony Stark à
l'époque du premier film Avengers qui a
pris conscience de la dangerosité de
l'univers et la future menace à venir
qui s'est traduite par l'arrivée du
fameux Titan Docteur Strange a lui aussi
désormais pris conscience des dangers du
multivers et pire que ça encore il a
découvert qu'il en était la cause dans
la plupart des
cas c'est de la bouche de Reed Richards
838 que Doctor Strange a appris ce
qu'était une incursion et ce que cela
impliqué pire que ça il en a même vu les
conséquences sauf qu'à chaque fois il a
réalisé qu'un strange était au cœur de
ces dernières et vous le savez désormais
qu'une incursion n'est pas le fruit du
hasard c'est une cause à une réaction du
multivers suite aux actions de quelqu'un
et pas n'importe qui docte strange 838
il a déclenché une incursion à cause
d'un rêve passerelle et a totalement
détruit un univers sinister strange sa
réalité est désormais le résultat d'une
incursion suite à sa mystérieuse défaite
et ses rêves passerelles notre docte
strange clleéa est apparu à la fin du
film pour lui révéler que ce dernier
vient de causer une incursion est-ce que
docte strange ne serait pas finalement
une sorte de singularité pour le MCU si
nous reprenons le cas d'Owen et bien
dans les comics les incursions sont
liées à ce dernier parce que les
Beyonders la mort d'Owen provoque une
incursion et rien d'autre et si nous
revenons sur le MCU et bien il y a
plusieurs éléments qui viennent appuyer
la possible singularité de Doctor
Strange nous rappelant au passage
subtilement le cas d'Owen ris peu
importe tout ce qu'il se passe dans le
multivers les actes de Wanda les voyages
d'America the marvels les événements de
Spider-Man no home actuellement les
incursions sont toujours liées à Doctor
Strange il y a aussi le concept que peu
importe l'univers docteor strange
devient docteor strange et toujours avec
le même visage son accident peut importe
de quelle manière il se traduit doit le
pousser à s'orienter vers les arm
mystiques l'ancien sait que Steven
strange arrivera un jour à Cartage et
deviendra l'un des plus grands sorciers
qu'il n'ait jamais existé c'est un point
immuable du temps et c'est pourquoi peu
importe l'univers où il se trouve
strange et Doctor Strange ces variants
ont tous su un accident de voiture 616
partage d'ailleurs les mêmes blessures
au niveau des mains que celui de 838 à
98 %. bref cependant bien que tout ceci
appuie la singularité de docte strange
on ne peut pas véritablement prouver à
100 % que seul lui est lié aux
incursions et ce serait quand même gros
malgré les explications du film les
raisons d'une incursion restent encore
plutôt flou actuellement et comme je le
disais un peu plus tôt par rapport à
l'adaptation deowen Riss le cas de
molculem est propre au comics Secret
Wars ne sera jamais le Secret Wars des
comics en revanche dans le le symbole
tout comme Owen ris Doct strange serait
une bombe à retardement pour l'univers
mais pas comme on pourrait l'entendre le
plus grand ennemi de docteor Strange
c'est docte strange il est un homme
destiné à être brisé à cause de son
accident et parce qu'il est arrogant
obsessionnel à vouloir tout contrôler il
devient par la suite un sorcier avec des
pouvoirs
divins
steven est un être singulier car il est
immensément puissant et terriblement
imparfait le strange de watif a annihilé
sa propre réalité parce qu'il ne
supportait pas la perte de Christine
sinister strange a déclenché une
incursion dans son propre univers et
probablement d'autres parce qu'il
n'était pas heureux et voulait être
auprès de Christine strange 38 arrogant
et dans le contrôle voulait gérer le cas
de Thanos tout seul Thunder strange se
croyait suffisamment supérieur pour
prendre le pouvoir d'America
Chavez Doct strange est une bombe à
retardement car à cause de ses
souffrances internes ses peurs et
traumatismes il est capable de causer le
pire les plus grandes annihilations et
c'est finalement ce qui explique qu'au
yeux de beaucoup de personnes il est
l'une des plus grandes menace pour le
multivers néanmoins malgré tout ça
strange a les capacités et le pouvoir de
nous proposer l'inverse et il est là le
message du film concernant Steven notre
Docteur Strange n'est désormais plus un
homme brisé et le moment où il répare sa
montre en est sa plus belle image Steven
l'a désormais changer contrairement à
ses variants Steven a dans Infinity war
fait la décision de lâcher prise et se
laisser partir pour miser sur Tony Stark
et le reste des Avengers il a avoué ses
peurs et son amour à Christine et s'est
libéré de ce poids en intériorisant
qu'il ne pourra jamais être avec elle il
a choisi de faire confiance et miser sur
America Chavez au lieu de lui prendre
son
pouvoir et maintenant si nous nous
tournons vers l'avenir quand on regarde
la fin du film traduit désormais le
changement clé strange a provoqué une
incursion et Cléa arrivant de la
dimension noire indique qu'ils doivent
désormais la réparer c'est la prochaine
direction de Strange et c'est un
indicateur pour le futur du MCU Steven
va découvrir comment stopper une
incursion ce qui veut dire qu'il sera
particulièrement lié à ce concept et sa
résolution comparé à la plupart des
héros en plus de contrebalancer avec le
destin funeste de ces autres Luis de
plus si les rumeurs s'avèrent vrai et
que Doctor Strange 3 nous amène les
événements de Times runout soit
l'événement qui précède Secret Wars dans
les comics et qui baigne à 100 % dans le
concept d'incursion où les univers
entrent en collision de partout et bien
là-bas Steven possède un rôle
véritablement crucial il va rencontrer
et devenir le dirigeant des prêtres
noirs des êtres multiversels usant de la
magie et tapis dans l'espace entre les
univers qui ont pour objectif de stopper
et ou d'empêcher les incursions cllea
qui a de grandes chances d'être une
prêtresse noire du coup permettra à
notre Steven strange d'intégrer une team
du multiver spécialisé dans la magie
tout ceci nous proposerait une véritable
direction pour strange 616 celui qui
réussira à devenir le plus grand
protecteur du multivers et non pas un
annihilateur comme les
autres enfin voilà je pense que nous
allons nous arrêter là je souhaitais
vous faire une vidéo sur Doctor Strange
qui est un personnage que j'adore mais
surtout le cas de moléculem c'était
vraiment un truc qui me trottait en tête
depuis un long moment j'espère que tout
ceci vous aura plu c'est une piste de
réflexion à vous de me dire vos avis vos
réflexions en commentaire ce que vous en
pensez et cetera le débat est ouvert je
remercie de tout cœur le frérot ho de
m'avoir accompagné sur la vidéo
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
et à laisser un petit pouce bleu allez
c'était argoroc ciao tout le
[Musique]
monde